this episode of shots of Oz brought to
you by Toyota
so I'm really into the topic of
serendipity moments of unexpected
relevance moments in which you find
yourself looking for something you find
something else where you realize is that
found is more conducive to your needs
than what we thought we were looking for
and Eric Davis says that serendipity
lives in the space of juxtaposition and
the space diverse he says that
juxtaposition is the basic formal
operating space of Sealand different in
space and which are more likely to make
unexpected connections between subjects
the spaces in which ideas a rich
diversity a rich ecology of stimulating
ideas can intermingle and create these
spaces of innovation in your head from
just you know finding these unusual
combinations among subject matter and he
talks about places like the city you
know which is density and its diversity
of viewpoints perspectives and memes you
know this super market of the music
creates these unexpected collisions and
creates that creativity but he also
talks about places like Burning Man
which is this vegetable where
juxtaposition is it reigns supreme you
know where piano against some like stark
desert contrast is next to like some
overgrown dice you know alluding to like
some Alice in Wonderland a scrap rabbit
hole you know next to some like crazy
naked girl and unique juxtaposition
floods you with dopamine floods you with
novelty just
awakens this lightning bolt of meaning
in the perceivers mind these heightened
pattern recognition rush you associate
with creativity so again it's all about
juxtaposition the juxtaposition of
extremes creates that basic formal
operating space